irises characters it's kind of greedy
coming out of her own when we're going
to see more photo Colton was it like to
play a female character who is not
defined by the relationship that she has
with the main male character um we will
see more of that hopefully in this
season I will say we haven't shot too
much of that yet if you've watched I
don't know where you guys are have you
seen three so three on Tuesday you
definitely get to see iris kind of be a
badass reporter so I think it's a tease
of what's to come for iris later in the
season
I'm always advocating and hoping for
more of that because that's kind of how
we know iris in the comic books is this
kind of a badass reporter so I just
don't know when that's going to kick
into full gear but what I've always
loved about iris is for her as a
character we see the slow burn of her
evolving as a woman you know she hasn't
season one she wasn't perfect and
perfect and she didn't have everything
together and so it's nice to see a woman
kind of evolve on-screen and your other
question which was what was it like to
be a female character that exists
outside of relationship
yeah it's it's actually quite nice and
I'm kind of always fighting it in the
fandom and porting world you know I
think people are always wondering when
as soon as I was going to get with Barry
when is that going to happen and I'm
always saying you know we as women and
as characters are so much more than the
men that we are associated with and so
I'm constantly trying to advocate that
for iris hey it would be great to see
her with Barry because that's kind of an
iconic couple right so it's really fun
that that's a possibility for our show
but what I get excited about is her
agency in life and what she can
contribute to team flash we have two
very strong role models and two very
strong characters in front of us
do you have a four see your characters
working together in some way in the
future in the DC in the greater DC TV
universe yet I don't know I mean
anything's a possibility with these
shows especially with legends of
tomorrow coming the crossovers that
we've already seen anything as possible
and I think that's what's so great about
Andrew mark Greg Geoff Johns I don't
know I think it would be great
I don't know much about arrow I've just
started kind of watching every Wednesday
night I happened to be off on Wednesdays
lately and so I'm just starting to get
into it
it'd be cool I don't know how our
characters would interact but yeah send
him over yeah um can I also ask Opel
we've got the mic on where you wee fans
of the comic books and you're aware of
that the greater world before you came
to
TV roles in your pants I mean for me I
had a really kind of casual relationship
with comic books you know and and what's
really been wonderful to be part of a
show like this is gives you that
opportunity to to explore those stories
that are so rich that maybe you weren't
familiar with and also just get to know
this incredible fan base I mean it's
it's really astonishing to me to witness
these sort of comic cons as they've
really grown and evolved and it kind of
I think speaks to the power of these
stories I mean comic books have been
around for a very long time obviously
and you know at their best versions they
can really take advantage of just great
storytelling and and kind of focusing on
on larger themes and so yeah I mean it
kind of feels like the possibilities are
endless with with comic book universes
when they're done well so I certainly
appreciate it a lot more now that I'm
working you know on something like this
um yeah comic books in terms of the the
actual comic no I didn't grow up with
those so they weren't really available
to me but I did grow up loving you know
Saturday morning cartoons so it was very
familiar with Batman Superman huge
Batman fan I've seen every Batman movie
I love Batman so I was very familiar
with this kind of comic idea but I
didn't know much about the flash I'd
never read a flash comic book and so
when I started to do that and I still do
it now to this day we kind of keep the
flash comics my makeup artist keeps them
on her table so that when I'm getting
ready I can kind of flip through it's
still surreal because iris is white and
like I'm reading these stories and I'm
like wait that's me and it's a really
cool thing because as a kid when I'm
watching Batman or Superman and I'm
watching the lowest lanes and the Vicki
veils it was never and imagining that I
would ever get to play that aunjanue so
it's cool that that that's happening
a lot of girls are watching that and are
inspired it's cool
you